[Music]
hello there
so the rift tour arrived on the island
and whether you like ariana or not
that was a solid event as usual epic
hinted at many story beats and packed
the event with secrets and easter eggs
my job today is to tell you about the
ones that i've spotted please think
about dropping a like and look here's my
creator code if you'd be so kind
anyway enough jibber jabber let's do
this
season seven has been all about an alien
invasion
extraterrestrials coming to the island
from an unknown location
while the mustard we call donald epic's
creative leader
gave us the name of that alien faction
the last reality
not only do we know their name we know
how this event is part of the story
donald ironically says this i think the
last reality is totally
not trying to abduct you onto the rift
or so they can see your memories for
information about the island
and the zero point so no worries just
enjoy
armed with this new information the
event completely feels different
as we travel through the void we see our
memories all around us
previous events and moments we've lived
through the floating island
the mecca fight we'll come back to that
one
peely's resurrection in season x season
x is here
and the world is destabilizing fast the
volcano
the storm king from save the world in
fort nightmares
[Music]
all these memories are being looked at
by the aliens the last reality
until they find the one they want kevin
the cube
the aliens are searching for the cube of
dark energy and the inverted reality
that brings
but here's another thing to note this
memory is not from our history
this image is of kevin the cube on the
current island
it looks to be here or maybe here okay
i'm not completely sure
but we know this is a memory we are yet
to experience
we know that fortnite loves to
foreshadow the future and it's yet
another nod to the return
of the cube we all miss
[Music]
after the section of the event in which
we were on the back of a giant cuddle
team leader which by the way looks to be
heavily inspired by the dr
zeus story of the lorax we finally came
face to face with the storm king
his third time in the game following the
first time we met him in save the world
where he was revealed to be part of the
cube he then returned in a non-canon
halloween battle
this time we took him out with an
aircraft you may not have noticed but
after the storm king is defeated
he becomes a void tornado which brings
down the plane
so i thought we'd do a little myth
busting what happens if you fail this
encounter
not shooting a single bullet well it
isn't that much to be honest the battle
ends the exact same way
but now you have the world record for
the lowest score on this event
we are then all revived and helped back
to our feet back on twitter
tim elec fortnite's live event director
said this about that scene
a major goal for the riftal was to
achieve a sentimental moment
an expression of support during trying
times in a way only fortnight can
take a moment to help each other and
elevate one another
it certainly worked after a year of hard
times in the world this is fortnite's
way to acknowledge that
before we break down the significance of
this i decided to follow a few of
fortnite's devs on twitter and
discovered their inspiration for this
light scene
have you guessed it trolls yeah those
people who write dead game in the
comments
for real i mean the little doll things
who have their own movie
in that scene the trolls are trapped in
the dark all alone but as they find each
other and their fear begins to subside
their color returns fortnite uses a
beacon of light
after reviving each player to do the
exact same thing who'd have thought that
trolls inspired fortnite
did you notice who helped us back to our
feet none other than drift
the first person taken from the real
world and put into fortnight
this isn't a coincidence because the
season drift arrived was the season that
introduced kevin the cube
and remember who was his bae bright
bomber
and her summer variant the beach bomber
these two were inseparable back in
chapter one
and this relationship was recently seen
carved on a tree declaring their love
for each other
although it looked like they were
crossed out maybe they're going through
bad times
if the aliens are looking back through
our memories of the cube bright bomber
and drift
are certainly part of that oh hold up a
minute mythbuster moment
what happens if we refuse to pick up the
beach bomber
i tested this hoping that she would be
eliminated but nope
we have no choice eventually we will do
the right thing and lift her back to her
feet
by the way did you notice there's a
drift variant with black hair instead of
blonde in here
it looks good please add it epic ariana
arrived next and we did some weird
things in bubbles and watched a 200-foot
grande on a swing
in fact this is a reference to one of
ariana's videos in which she does the
same thing
swings in the clouds the video is cold
breathing if you want to see it yourself
the thing i'd like to look at though is
this scene ariana manipulates reality
breaking gravity and our expectations
this scene is actually based on a piece
of art by m.c escher named relativity
it's a mind freak which has three ways
to look at it showing us perspective
is everything before i turn this into an
art lecture here's the same concept in
the movie labyrinth
i think we can safely say fortnite's
reality is nothing like our own
oh and another ariana easter egg can be
found here ariana uses her freakishly
big hammer to break through the walls of
this dimension
and many grande fans know that they've
seen this before it's a remix on the
video
god is a woman where the girl from sam
and cat eats her hammer smashing a glass
window to smithereens
fortnite straight up like this so they
took it ggs
let's go back a bit to the pre-event
lobby where we were all waiting for the
event to begin
i'm sure you've noticed all the alien
paraphernalia and those projectors too
standing on these let us see ourselves
larger than life
but if we stayed here too long our own
projections would kick us off to let
somebody else have a go
stop hugging it a cool addition was that
our emotes were replicated
but in good old fortnite fashion
somewhat straight up broken
my favorite is this one look how tiny
the tiny chair is
tiny chairs are awesome i'm not sure
where to put this one so um
here it is it looks like human bill got
naked
during the event i have no words to go
here
sun's out plums out you do you nobody's
judging
so they're the main 12 things i wanted
to talk about but there is one more
thing i'm going to go a little bit
deeper on a theory which was hinted at
both in the event and by the mustard we
call donald
that's of the paradigm for many years
i've believed paradigm and singularity
are the same person
but every time i bring it up someone
gets butthurt well recently donald told
us singularity is far more important to
the storyline than we realize
and more recently he's telling us the
importance of the paradigm going so far
to make her his skin during the event
and to add to this there is a memory we
see of the mecha fight
it flashes past with the sword and we
know that this character was created by
singularity
once the mech saved us it flew away into
the atmosphere
never to be seen again and how did the
aliens get here this season
they just flew here out of nowhere okay
point two now look at the similarities
between the aliens i.e the last reality
and singularity their armor looks highly
similar i put it to you ladies and
gentlemen that singularity was piloting
the mech that left us in chapter one
and she will return in chapter two as
the leader of the alien race
perhaps their queen i'd love to know
your thoughts on that
i'm slightly addicted to fortnite law i
hope you are too let me know your
thoughts
so that was 12 easter eggs and a random
theory from me too i'm adam you're
awesome
here's a bunch of legends from my
discord this time who used code adamaru
this week
i'll be back in my twitter dms this week
to thank other people who are kind
enough to support
me too it's been a pleasure i'm gonna go
watch the concert again see you next
[Music]
time
[Music]